it was never a partnership of equal
measures held together by an independent
Prime Minister Italy's two populist
parties the far-right League and the
anti-establishment five style movement
are comfortably wedded to each other in
a coalition of convenience between the
two the dominating force had always been
the league with its strident
anti-immigrant policies and heavy
reliance on its leader Matteo Salvi
knees combative personality and it
proved popular eclipsing the 5-stars
presence in the coalition taking
advantage of his surging popularity
nearly two weeks ago salvini took a
gamble and announced that his party's
alliance with five star was over the
league put forward a motion of no
confidence in the government and salvini
called for elections that could make him
prime minister call it hubris or a nil
time intervention the move hadn't quite
worked out as salvini had hoped
instead the five star movement in the
opposition Democratic Party began to
talk openly of forming a coalition among
themselves leaving salvini out in the
cold
his supporters call him the captain but
his latest venture has left him adrift
faced with a prospect of losing power
salvini backed down and said he would be
prepared to stick with five star with
perhaps a cabinet shuffle but for his
one-time allies the damage had already
been done but it won't be an easy ride
for five-star either their decision to
go into coalition with a far-right party
has cost them half of their supporters a
humiliating defeat at this year's
European elections and the league has
overtaken the five star movement to
become the most popular party in Italy
the country is going right in this
moment the population wants economic
reform in liberal terms once market
reforms and the fast that movement have
always been embracing leftists economic
policies so I don't think they will come
back and a political approval from the
masses of Italians who are somehow
demanding new elections
it is a bitter breakup for two parties
which were always ill suited for each
other a fight for Italy's identity
between the far-right and more centrist
forces and with a weakening economy
close to a recession the country cannot
afford any worsening of its political
turmoil in the months ahead
Sonia Jaeger al-jazeera Rome